foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
serve as the pastor teacher servant
leader of the Saint Paul Missionary
Baptist Church in Gretna parenthetically
speaking mcdonneville Louisiana this is
my home church and I've been passing
here for 23 years
um I have a Godly a gorgeous and a
gracious wife Miranda Audrey and three
sons two here on Earth with us and one
in heaven or indeed Grant Jr
word went out that Oren was murdered I
was in Houston Texas so I got a call
from my aunt then my brother
and I had to step out of a meeting and
so I began to process that and it's a
tough field to swallow
he was by his uh girlfriend's house she
was living with her own grandparents at
the time
and uh they had just come back from
lunch and they just was relaxing and
chilling
and allegedly her father came to the
house and summoned Oren and uh let him
um outside to the backyard and there
allegedly were two perpetrators
who shot my son multiple times as he
tried to run from them
the detectives are doing their work
hopefully they can discover uh who they
are and and bring Justice to this
situation because my son did not deserve
that
and it's been six months and I don't
even know if I've started
to grieve I guess
officially in my own way and I and I
made I stay busy so and I probably stay
busy to kind of keep myself
from you know grieving
they are difficult days
you know that I I go to sleep with him
on my mind I sleep with him on my mind I
wake up with him on my mind
he he had uh a call on his life
and uh you know on uh Tuesday August the
2nd something precious was taken from me
and from this world and they're going to
miss that contribution but we're keeping
his memory alive we're keeping his
message alive and we're keeping his
ministry alive
his message is love
unity and peace stop the violence
[Music]
we have a great church here at St Paul
and uh they want us to honor Oren by
having a brunch in honor of his uh
memory and so we kicked this day off
with a worship service and then a brunch
and then we had a 21 balloon balloon
release for his uh birthday and we had
sporties uh Brass Band to lead the
second line
okay
[Music]
he was a special child on peculiar rare
he was royalty he was my prince I had a
lot of Promise uh
he was our youngest of three sons
you know on blades through high school
was in uh college at Nunez Community
College
I love music he was a percussionist a
drummer and um from the very uh outset
of his life I mean as a two-year-old I
would be preaching uh you know from the
pulpit
and he would be there with his mama and
when I would kind of get to the end of
my sermon where we celebrate and get
excited he would get out in the middle
hours and every move I made he made if I
screamed he screamed and so uh he just
brought a lot of Joy to the family I
mean he he was adorable funny you know
love to laugh love to play and he loved
children
some people every time they come to the
church they just uh you know have memory
of Orem because he was charismatic in a
way he beat the drums and he beat the
drums without one lesson
it just was in him he was he was born to
beat the drugs therefore in light of uh
his debt his Beat Goes On
[Music]
cause I was an advocate before but when
Oren was murdered it just accelerated uh
my advocacy I've done seminars on peer
mediation uh parenthetically speaking
conflict resolution uh gun violence and
mental health so uh we we recognize uh
that we're in a dark place you know in
society but there are people who are
resilient and bring hope to our children
that they might have a great future
my church is not just a church in the
city it's a church for this city
30 days
after Oren was murdered I had a rally I
called on
pastors public officials police parents
and people
and we did it in the area where he was
murdered and so it is Our intention to
visit different
hot spots in the city to make our
prisons fail
to stop the violence
I'm on focused I'm very intentional
um this has not weakened me
it has strengthened me uh I'm like a
hurricane over hot water
in August the end of August
I'm gaining strength and I'm coming
through and like the crime dog McGruff
we're going to take a bite out of crime
[Music]